[Music]
book review doki-doki
hello everybody I'm back did you think I
forgot no I did it I just been not doing
my homework Sumi Masen I am sorry when I
was in Japan last month I didn't really
have much chance to read I my time there
was limited so I really just wanted to
focus on being in Japan there's been a
lot of news articles about book club I
don't know if you read them and so some
of them are great just praising the idea
that obviously getting more people into
reading a British bookstore a very very
big British bookstore they had a select
table of books and there were all books
that I had reviewed and it made me think
wow it definitely had an influence on
sales if they feature these books and in
a specific way it's not like they'd said
pity pile or anything like that but it's
cool should I force anything else
positive into this before I begin I
don't think we need to do that thank you
now first book I read was the dice man
written by Luke Reinhart this was
suggestion by Brad all right for Brad
Thank You Brad for suggesting a lot of
you guys suggested this book as well and
I can definitely see why I think Brad
told me that he read it when he was
younger and I think it's the kind of
book I would probably appreciate if I
was younger as well not saying that it's
stupid or anything like that it's just
it has a lot of flaws that I thought was
a bit hard to over over see it's not a
saying look doesn't matter the book is
written by Luke Reinhart who is also
conveniently the protagonist mmm how
strange if all is a story of Luke who is
psychiatrist he's very successful he
earns a lot of money he has his wife he
has his kids but he just doesn't feel
happy where he is in life he's his best
friend is advancing before him even
though he's not as clever as he is he
just feels stuck in a rut basically so
in a drunken idea late at night he
decides that he's going to roll a dice
and if it lands on a six I think it was
a sex doesn't matter
he is going to rape his best friend's
wife who has been sort of flirting with
him a little bit and here it sort of
shows how amateurish the rider is or
maybe just needs a better editor I don't
know there's really no reason for him to
want to rape his best friend's wife I
understand that he needs to undergo this
drastic change of character but they
justify it as oh well she liked it more
than I did I feel weird I've been
talking about it and it's not like I'm
prude or anything like that but
nevertheless this event has such a
drastic change of his character that he
becomes the Diceman and he decides to
live his life by the roll of the dice he
will write down a couple things that he
wants to do and a couple of things that
he doesn't want to do and he plays them
on the number of the dice so if it rolls
a 1 or a 2 he'll do this 2 to 3 or 4
he'll do this five or six either this so
that determines his life and it's
interesting in a way how that makes him
break free from his rut essentially his
character that's just too comfortable a
lot of times it's obvious what you want
to do and you always go for the obvious
choice and he explains that but the dice
man has you there's so many things that
you miss out on by not doing and that
never gets to live because you always go
with the obvious choice and by
constantly going with the obvious choice
you may end up too comfortable and in
the way that Luke was in the beginning
of the novel Luke really decides that
he's going to push this for scientific
purposes or for his studies he's going
to push the limit of the dice and
following the dice as a godly figure to
it's very limits it's not like the whole
idea of flipping a coin is anything new
it's not like there's anything that
special about it but it becomes a cult
and he becomes a cult leader of that of
the dice it's an interesting concept of
self control also letting go of that
control to something else and while
reading it I was feeling like I want to
try this out when I was in Japan for
example I mean might say a lot of times
the things that we enjoyed the most
we're not that
we had planned for but things that we
just happened to stumble upon which i
think is why what is trying to get at
the book very confidently says on the
cover this book will change your life
it won't I really enjoyed it at the
first half but the second half was just
unnecessary I think it tried too hard to
be commercialized they the story takes
almost like a movie like plot or the FBI
is after him and there's so many sex
scenes in this book I think there's like
30 sex scenes in it and it just became
cringe-worthy after a while I'm like
this is just ridiculous
at the end of it it sort of made me
question the the skill of the author and
if the concept of the dice was even that
great to begin with it just seems so
like some sort of pseudo Psychiatry and
who knows maybe that's what it was
trying to mock anyway next I read stoner
by John Williams this was a book that
when he came out it barely sold anything
but then later fifty years later he got
translated and it picked up in
popularity now it's very highly regarded
when I explained my favorite novel to
people or at least an OLE that I really
enjoyed a lot of times I met with a
skeptic look like that doesn't sound
interesting at all what are you talking
about a good testimony of a good writer
is that if you can tell a seemingly
uninteresting story and captivate your
your reader that's a great way to test
it and I think stoner is exactly that
now I was reading this and I kept
thinking when is the punchline coming
when is the weed joke coming I was on
page 420 and I realized I've just spent
hours reading a boring book about a
boring man's life it has nothing to do
with weed not a single weed reference
I'm just kidding obviously it's actually
a really great book I really enjoyed
reading it it follows a story a William
stoner which can be summarized as live
sucks and then you die so the world
and let's get high 4:20 everybody it's
so cringe-worthy jokes I'm sorry William
stoner grows up on a farm he goes to
study Agricole
sure and a part of his study he it's
obligatory to study English literature
and he completely falls in love with it
and he loves a nice which his studies
completely to literature instead of
agriculture and at the day of his
graduation he very selfishly tells his
parents I'm not coming back to help at
the farm I'm going to keep studying to
become a teacher I can't relate to that
at all I escaped to Italy to become a
youtuber and abandon my studies so maybe
I can full stone or too much in this it
sets the swing of the story in all the
stoners life whenever something positive
happens to stoner so it's met with
something negative he he falls in love
with literature but at the cost of
disappointing his parents he falls in
love with a woman and they get married
very quickly but then he discovers that
she's actually a very horrible to him
and they don't match at all so anytime
something positive happen to stoner it's
met with something negative he loves
teaching his students at school but it
becomes very hard for him to do so
because of the department he gets a
daughter that he loves very much and
care for but the daughter after a while
sort of turns against him because of his
wife it just keeps on rocking back and
forth for stoner and you just have to
when reading it you can't help but
appreciate his immense stoicism and how
much he endures of bad behavior from
other people that just brings him down
you just want to pet stoner in the back
and say it's okay you did your best man
I always try and fight for some sort of
ideas in there I don't know if I'm right
or wrong but the way I saw it is that
there's two sides of the coin in life
you're gonna be happy sometime and
you're gonna be unhappy sometime and you
can just hope that you end up on one
side more than the other just because
you endure a lot of pain and a lot of
bad behavior and just because you're a
good person and work really hard for the
things you love that doesn't necessarily
mean happiness is some sort of reward or
something that's oh
to you it does doesn't work like that
that's just a state of life and that's
the balance that we all have to go
through stoner does it in such grace and
the way he endures at all you just hang
you can't help but look up to him and
his character in a lot of ways he's a
hero and I think that's how the author
described him as as an angel in the end
there's a fantastic read I really
enjoyed it from start to finish I think
this was the novel that I find the
easiest to read and flow through so way
if it sounded interesting give it a go
next up we have Crime and Punishment
it's a classic you've definitely heard
about this have you heard about this is
written by a Fuehrer Dostoevsky in 1866
it was the longest one I read and I I
mean that sometimes this book was very
hard to get through but the parts that
shines in this novel truly shines and I
do understand why it's a classic and I
want to just focus on the bits that I
really really enjoyed which is the bits
revolving around the main character
Raskolnikov Raskolnikov is a young man
who lives in st. Petersburg he is like I
said young attractive intelligent and
since his father died his mother and
sister had focused on him a lot more
which led him to come up with the insane
idea that he is going to murder and
robbed an elderly pawn broker named
Ivanova he sees a phenomena as a lesser
human a bad human and she has the only
thing that Raskolnikov doesn't have
which is well-versed Kanaka was very
poor and he sees it almost as an
injustice following Raskolnikov's ideas
around why he wants to commit this
murder is the best where I really really
enjoyed I don't know what it is about
following someone's internal thoughts
about something that's just bizarre and
insane the truest honest thoughts about
someone and I think that's why I really
like Japanese literature as well
nevertheless Raskolnikov doesn't see
anything wrong with murdering this woman
he thinks is it's justified and he
almost sees it as a practice of can he
commit this crime is he able to commit
the perfect crime even and he sort of
sneers at other people that has
being able to commit the perfect crime
so he sneaks into Yvonne Domino's
apartment and he murders her with an axe
unfortunately Yvonne de nos stepsister
enters the scene of the crime and
Raskolnikov is forced to murder her as
well now obviously this wasn't part of
the plan and he sort of very clumsily
escapes that the murder scene and he
only gets a little bit of gold from the
apartment but still somehow he managed
to escape without anyone seeing him
commit the crime he hides all the gold
and the murder weapon and then were
followed with the second part of the
book that the punishment we get to
follow Raskolnikov's internal struggle
with through conversations with other
people of why he committed this crime
and what made him want to actually do it
if you didn't take the gold what was the
real reason behind it and the guilt with
it the bits are especially enjoyed was
the last third of the book Raskolnikov
wants to confess to his love Sonia that
he committed this murder and he stumble
upon his words and he stumbles upon his
reasoning that before was so clear to
himself but when explaining it to
someone else he just can't get the right
reason and words out and I really
enjoyed this bit I don't know it's just
it's so interesting following these
thoughts and the change in brush Golikov
eventually he turns himself and despite
the fact that he there was no real
evidence against him I think he was just
so tired of dealing with this internal
struggle and conflict and even though he
doesn't necessarily think that what he
did was wrong he compares his his murder
with what other what other people have
done in the past and not received any
punishment for people doing even worse
things than him and getting away with it
so why should he have to feel bad but he
turns himself in because I'm Sonia and
the one he loves and he wants to serve
his punishment and I think the epilogue
would they explain this was a bit forced
these classic novels they always have
the very strict conclusion to them at
least what I read so far so maybe that's
why the reason why I written risk only
Cove struggled so much maybe he had
found logic behind what he
but he put himself above society and
that was his demise what do you think
have you read it what what do you think
personally I was extremely bored with
the family conflict that was going on
throughout this book it didn't interest
me at all but nevertheless I really
enjoyed it I would love to read more
from dose of jet ski in the future I'm
told that the idiot is even better are
you still with me next up we have no
longer human with Osamu Dazai
I feel my voice is just different
talking about this it's just such a sad
story
it follows a story of Oba and we follow
it through some notebooks that he has
left behind I love Japanese literature I
really enjoyed reading Murakami but I
love reading Yukio Mishima and nowadays
I they so beautifully describe the
internal monologue in it where the
protagonist is so extremely self-aware
of the interaction and ideas that they
have I'm explaining this really poorly
but essentially the way Japanese culture
are so polite it's hard to understand
the true character behind a person and
to then read a Japanese novel by by
these authors so so brilliantly
described I just feel so immersed into
it funnily enough that's exactly well
there's nothing funny about it but
that's exactly what no longer human is
all about the main character Oba can't
present his true self to other people he
has this facade that he hides behind and
he makes jokes to other people too to
hide his true self and he's extremely
self aware of this fact and we don't we
don't get to follow the jokes that he
makes other people instead we we get to
follow his ideas of how he thinks other
people perceive his jokes
it doesn't sound interesting at all I
says I just wanted to give you an idea
of how he's written basically something
that I've really grown to appreciate
over the years is honesty if I noticed
that someone isn't being really themself
or being honest I always wonder if you
not honest then who are you what are you
I don't want to play along with your
facade and sometimes in this novel
oh but someone calls out oppa for not
being genuine maybe he laughed in a way
that they didn't think was really
authentic and he recollects on these
moments in his life where he did get
called out for his facade and he he
describes that in such immense pain that
someone is discovering that he is an
actually human the story of no longer
human is an incredibly sad story
especially afterwards finding out about
the author himself dassai who shares so
much with the main character he was
sexually assaulted as a child which is
most likely what led to him protect
himself behind this facade the the
double attempt of suicide with his wife
where the wife died but he survived and
the guilt I will keep on living problem
with alcoholism and drugs all these
things that the character oppa goes
through has happened to dassai at some
point in his life as well the author at
the end of the book there's a very
chilling moment where oppa is talking to
his his friend Okeke I think his name
was I don't remember
and who kiki is sort of his character
opposite it's his friend but almost so
sort of his enemy he's very direct and
very straightforward unlike oppa who
hides behind a facade Okeke and whenever
ho kiki is involved in his life
it sort of triggers these bad behaviors
you know where he turns to alcohol and
all these things in this moment they're
both drinking and they're discussing the
crime and punishment funnily and
discussing what the antonym of crime is
and Oba sort of goes off as he usually
does in his analytic way of what it
actually is
while who kiki is just sort of not
really following and making this really
dumb assumptions who Kiki then leaves
the room and commits adultery with Ava's
wife Oba doesn't do anything to
interfere with this and it's at this
moment
when you read the novel it's because
he's no longer human and this happened
to dancing as well and it's clearly a
very personal tale reading it at almost
in retrospect it almost feels like a
goodbye and the same year 1948 assist
novel came out that's I you know he had
multiple suicide attempts finally he
succeeded to commit suicide by drowning
himself in the river and his body was
found on the day of its 49th birthday I
feel like I didn't do it justice by
reading this book first this is clearly
the final chapter and I want to try and
be more careful in the future when I I
pick a new author to make sure that I
read read in the right order
I absolutely loved reading this book - I
clearly is a phenomenal writer and this
is everything I would want from her
novel next up I read Yukio Mishima
Sonnen steel I'm not gonna discuss this
book because I'm think I want to save
you Mishima for another time I just
wanted to give a quick thanks to blue D
on Twitter for sending me their copy of
the book I couldn't find one before I
left to Japan and I really really wanted
to read it it was funny I I walked
around with a book long story short I
needed to put a paper in something
without crinkling it and so I was using
the book because it's very big it's
already becoming too long a lot of other
people saw me holding this book in Japan
and they were all oh you kill me yukio
mishima I don't know if it's I get I
didn't realize how popular it was I
wonder who looks up to
yukio mishima Inge
super fascinated by Mishima but we'll
save that for another time next up for
next week we're going to read inferno by
August Strindberg I want to read as
spring snow I think it's called by Yukio
Mishima and runaway horses by Yukio
Mishima I'm gonna be a little bit
selfish and just read books that I
genuinely just want to read I'm sorry
other than that I just want to say
thanks for all the support on the book
review it's been fantastic I always
doubt myself
if it's really worth it or not to make
these but all the positive support and
all the comments has been great so thank
you very much that's it for me for now
I'll see you by the end of the month
with another book review you can read
all of them or none of them but I'll see
you that good bye